being here in Paris honestly it's like
really nerve-wracking but I'm not trying
to focus on anything negative in this
week's episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Kim returns to Paris for the first time
since being robbed at gunpoint in 2016
the last time I was there you know
obviously like a horrific experience for
me Kimmy a heads overseas for Kanye's
BFF Virgil a blows runway show for Louis
Vuitton
and Kim admits she was having a tough
time I'm just like hypersensitive to
this right now but in the end she
remembers why she loved traveling to the
City of Lights in the first place
I don't think I'll ever really forget my
experiences in Paris the good or the bad
and I think that's okay like it all you
know has made me who I am and thinking
about it I feel like I could go back and
I could spend more time and feel safe
and comfortable I mean I think
everything and life happens for a reason
even if it's really traumatic and I
learned from it I grow from it and I'm a
better person because of it and I'm
doing totally fine
I think that this is such a near and
dear cause to my heart and I know to
your heart so I just think it would be a
really nice thing for us to do meanwhile
the ladies got together to play poker
for charity ET caught up with some of
the fam before the event in July I laugh
a lot it's just my kind of nervous laugh
I could have a really good hand I could
have a really bad hand but I've never
played before the whole family no one's
played before but I swear I'm really
good
not much fun that you guys get to do
stuff like this together all the girls
come out I mean is it just a fun ladies
day boy yeah for sure
I got to learn a bit about poker which I
didn't really know much about before but
yeah it's it's exciting that's always to
do stuff with the family apparently
Kendall learns a lot outlasting all of
her sisters in the tournament that I'm
the last one standing
that's just what they get
[Music]